to all cubits eventually as far as noise goes it's pretty extreme but one thing that we can do is to consider a convex
combination of this Channel and the identity Channel with perhaps a small probability Epsilon for complete
depolarization this is a less extreme form of noise where a given Cubit state will mostly be left alone but there is
some small chance that it becomes completely mixed geometrically we can think about this as a slight contraction of the block sphere toward the center
and by the way we can do something similar with the completely def phasing Channel to model the process of decoherence for instance where things
become slightly more classical through some process so those are three basic examples of Cubit channels and we'll
come back to them mainly as a source of examples throughout the remainder of the lesson next we'll discuss mathematical
representations of channels starting with a basic question linear mappings from vectors to vectors can always be
represented by matrices in a familiar way which is that the action of the linear mapping is described by matrix
Vector multiplication but channels are linear mappings from matrices to matrices not vectors to vectors so in
general how can we express channels in mathematical terms sometimes for special channels we'll have a simple formula
that describes them and that was the case in the examples of Cubit channels that we already discussed but that isn't
practical in general because there won't always be such a nice formula as a point of comparison in the simplified
formulation of quantum information we use unitary matrices to represent operations on Quantum State vectors
every unitary Matrix represents a valid operation and every valid operation can be expressed as a unitary Matrix so in
essence what this question is asking is how do we do this for channels and the answer to this question is that there are in fact multiple ways to represent
channels in mathematical terms in particular we'll discuss three different ways of representing channels that are
named after three individuals whose work played an important part in their development hin spring Krauss and Choy
first we'll see how these different representations work and then in the last part of the lesson we'll see how the three representations relate and in
particular how we can convert between them we'll also see that these representations precisely capture the requirements that we have on channels
namely that they're linear mappings and that they always transform density matrices into density matrices even when
they're applied to just one part of a compound system first up are Stein spring representations Willam Forest Stein
spring was a mathematician who didn't work on Quantum information and Stein spring representations as I'll describe
them are in some sense just a derivative of his work on operator theory in the 1950s but this work was most certainly
an important part of the development of the mathematics that Quantum channels are based on the idea behind this way of representing channels is that every
channel can be implemented in a certain way that I'll now describe first we form a compound system consisting of the
input to whatever Channel we're implementing together with an initialized workspace system then a
unitary operation is performed on The Compound system and finally whatever part of the resulting compound system
corresponds to the output of the channel is left alone or output and the rest is discarded or traced out it's helpful to
express this in the form of a diagram and it's simplest to start with the special case in which the input and the
output systems are the same this diagram by the way is just like a Quantum circuit diagram except that the wires
represent arbitrary systems and not necessarily single cubits so we start with the input system X being in some
State row we introduce an initialized workspace system W and in this diagram I'm presuming that Zer is a classical
state of w and we're taking k0 to be the initialized state of the system but we could alternatively fix any pure state
of w and view that as the initialized state we then perform some unitary operation on the pair WX X and then
Trace out the workspace system and output X here in the diagram by the way I'm using the ground symbol from
electrical engineering to indicate that W is being discarded that's not necessarily conventional and you won't
find that symbol in kcit there you just ignore the cubits that you're not interested in the point is that I just want to have a symbol that makes it
clear that we're discarding the system for the purposes of this discussion in general we don't necessarily need the
input and the output systems to be the same so we can have for instance an output system y along with a garbage
system G that gets traced out in order for U to be unitary it has to be a square Matrix so there's an assumption
here that the pair g y together has the same number of classical States as the pair WX for example maybe these systems
consist of cubits and the input system X consists of 5 cubits and W consists of 10 cubits say so U is a unitary
operation on 15 cubits it could then be that y consists of just four cubits which means that g consists of 11 cubits
or maybe these aren't cubits at all all that's important is that WX together and gy together have the same number of
classical States so that you can be unitary a description of a channel like this is called a Stein spring representation of the channel now it's
pretty straightforward to argue that any mapping fi that can be described in this way is in fact a valid channel in
particular if we start with the density Ma Matrix and then tack on an additional workspace system then we'll certainly be
left with a density Matrix we already observed that applying a unitary operation gives us a valid Channel and
if we have a density Matrix of a compound system and we Trace out one of the systems then again we'll be left with a density Matrix so when we compose
these steps we'll be guaranteed that it always transforms density matrices into density matrices and it's also linear
what's not at all clear at this point is that every channel can indeed be implemented in this way for some choice
of the workspace system and the garbage system as well as the unitary operation U of course but that is true and we'll
see why by the end of the lesson here's an example of a Stein spring representation for the completely def
phasing Cubit Channel and to be clear now the wires are cubits and this is an ordinary controlled
knate it's very simple the input Cubit is on the top and we introduced a workspace Cubit initialized to the zero
statee we then perform a controlled knot operation where the input Cubit is the control and the workspace Cubit is the
Target and then the workspace Cubit is traced out intuitively speaking it makes sense
that this should implement the completely def phasing Channel because the controlled notate kind of acts like a standard basis measurement on the top
Cubit by copying its classical State onto the bottom Cubit and then the result gets thrown
away but we can also go through a calculation and of course it's a good idea to do that because we really